[Musica]
signore e signori
stasera siamo lì a far baldoria
siamo a fare veramente un casino stasera
non vedo l'ora si carica cari curry ma
anche lui è carico come carico vede
l'ora lewis di stasera siamo pranzando e
ci hanno portato i pass del wind day
wind summer festival
ma questo è il tuo qualche foto è
diretta rega ma perché questa foto
perché c'è il microfono voglio sempre un
cantante
grazie ragazzi giulia ma che cazzo aia
lesbica finalmente è arrivato il vostro
scenografo lo presentiamo presenta al
cenno grafo ea noi ci facciamo come dico
io aree da mou qua come a casa mia al
terzo piano dei fuori voi un solo un gas
chiavi o ama che ama che dica elezioni
lo so posso metterlo questa però non è
carino da disse gabri può suonare che
aveva rovinato a me provina bugia
[Risate]
[Musica]
eccome
una giocata
insegnate andare
mi farò
[Musica]
ragazzi siamo ai camerini abbiamo tutti
camerino ci siamo noi marino e gabry
ponte favi genoa non ci sei tu via via
via fuori dalle balle cazzo è lesbica
madonna è battuta sin parker a questo
nostro camerino mi stanno per dare uno
degli attrezzi chiusero stasera laga
questo è un ak47 ma è carica ma è
anch'esso creduto io non so se funziona
chi possiamo chiedere di andare a
prendere la targa ai critici c'è questa
non ha mai avuto i marziani e vantaggi e
arrivo capri ponte a sgridare fa vigenti
sono ragazzi ok
[Musica]
difetti questa cosa che hai detto
mi metti la cipria larghe tese fumata
gli uomini che frequenti tu o dai non
era una cattiva d'azzardo me tocca ti
denuncio da avvicinare un quella roba ma
è cazzo è capito dai dai che questo
platinette sul palco ma dai
ma siamo stiamo per entrare sul fatto to
be the colour giulia e carica
[Musica]
guardate quanta gente c'era gara
incredibile
c'è anche lo zio max
[Musica]
storica ma lasciato dall'altra parte del
palco maledetti e dove entrare da qua
adesso blogger o tutto in live c'è
piazza del popolo che piena e non mi sto
per niente cagando sotto
[Applauso]
non sarà tutti
che voglia di parlare un po
[Applauso]
non c'è
[Musica]
[Applauso]
dopo il ponte
ma vorrei presentarvi due amici che
hanno fatto male
canzone io torniamo facendo un po di
casino signore e signori
[Applauso]
[Musica]
quando è
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no
peccato
mi fa
[Applauso]
[Musica]
un mondo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]
ilario
il ragazzo dentro
porca vacca
ma qua
anche apple sopportare di come tutte le
sere
[Musica]
grazie